I texted Sandler.
Yeah.
And he sent me three texts, and I'm wondering,
I need you to decode them, Judd.
Okay.
So we're gonna play what is Sandler saying?
Okay. (laughs)
All right.
He wrote,
(audience applauds)
"Treading water in a pool."
Well, I think that means that,
okay, we lived in this apartment,
like a really bad apartment in North Hollywood.
And everyday Adam would to,
I guess this is what he thought exercise was,
'cause he wanted to be in good shape,
that he would tread water in the pool
for long amounts of time and be like,
"This is good for your abs."
And he would just sit there, treading water.
(audience laughs)
And then I remember...
I obviously would never do it.
The next text he sent me says,
"Never worked out together."
Never, no, I never worked out ever.
Okay, and then the next text says, "Sun tan bed
burned tush."
So then Adam would go get like,
he would go to like a tanning booth.
And so he went to a tanning booth,
and then one day, he's like,
"You should get a tan, get a tan."
I'm like, oh, maybe I should get a tan.
So I did it.
I don't know what I did wrong.
So I'm in there in my underwear,
I don't know if I positioned things wrong,
I was sweating too much, but I feel like the tanning booth,
maybe my sweat boiled and just burned my butt.
(Drew laughs)
Well, okay, so your book, there's a stain on this book.
I was with my daughters, we were in Hawaii
and a cockroach ran into the room
and my daughter started screaming.
So I grabbed your book
and just started killing it with the book.
I thought maybe you were either gonna be mad
or think it was awesome.
That's what it's there for, murder. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
I also, literally, I...
I really had a hard time sort of choosing
which chapter I loved the most,
but I think it has to be the David Letterman.
And this conversation with him
was like something I had never heard.
First of all, we all wanted to be like him.
We were all inspired by how groundbreaking he was.
I went to a taping of his show
within the first three months when I was a kid.
And now that he's not doing the show,
he's a little more available to talk to people
and tell us how he's doing and what his life is like.
And then we get a chance to thank him.
At the end of the interview, I said to him,
"I just want you to know, you changed so many of our lives
and you inspired us so much."
And he said?
And he said, "That's right, Judd.
There'd be no comedy without me." (laughs)
(upbeat bright music)